americans held hostage behind enemy
lines day 47
and welcome to hannity this busy
breaking news night day 47 with hundreds
of americans their families thousands of
american green card holders eligible to
live in this country thousands of our
allies abandoned by joe biden in
afghanistan they are hostages of the
taliban he's not mentioned our fellow
americans that he abandoned in 31 days
joe it's repulsive and tonight joe biden
and his fellow democrats are more
concerned about getting a political win
right here at home rather than think
about this anyway as we speak joe and
his fellow socialist comrades they're
now desperate to pass
two separate trillion dollar spending
bills a so-called infrastructure bill
that costs 1.2 trillion dollars on top
of that the other
build back better plan which is a social
welfare bill it's basically aoc's green
new deal that costs a whopping 3.5
trillion dollars money we do not have
and we'll never be able to pay back keep
in mind the whopping 6 trillion dollars
in emergency covert relief spending that
has already been allocated and for
reference let's go back to 2019. the
entire federal budget was only 4.4
trillion dollars so
where are we going to get the extra 10
trillion in new spending that joe is
claiming won't cost you a single penny
well in two ways one taxes the build
back better plan it raises taxes on
corporations but they don't pay taxes
you pay those taxes raises taxes on
small businesses individuals and
families and after they take a bite at
the apple though when you die they'll
take an extra 61 cents of every dollar
you might have in your piggy bank
everyone in america will feel the impact
of these taxes doesn't matter if you're
wealthy poor middle class somewhere in
between corporations businesses will not
sit back they're not going to take the
loss they will pass that tax on to you
the consumer you will pay these taxes
everything you buy will become more
expensive that's not all the second way
the federal government will
raise funds is through what they call
quantitative easing in other words it's
going to print money now this causes
inflation now that means your paycheck
becomes less and less valuable and again
everything you buy will once again
become more expensive your grocery bill
will be higher everything you buy at the
drugstore will be higher the cost to
fill up your gas tank will be higher to
heat and cool your home that'll be
higher raw materials like lumber and
aluminum they're already becoming higher
and more expensive and housing and rents
will go up as well and by the way this
isn't theoretical it's already happening
the fed has been working overtime to
print enough money to pay for the six
trillion dollars in emergency covert
relief spending and now in for inflation
thanks to joe biden's horrific policies
is now at a 13-year high now add to all
of that economic disaster the fact that
joe biden gave up the energy
independence that he inherited from
donald trump donald trump accomplished
energy independence for the first time
in 75 years in this country and we all
benefited low cost to fill up our gas
tank lower heating and cooling costs
delivery for all the things you buy in
your grocery store cheaper you save
money gas is now on average about a buck
fifty more per gallon nationwide heating
and cooling your home goes up again here
and everything you buy will cost more on
top of the inflation that he is causing
and that's not enough for this radical
democratic party now they've gone full
comrade socialist they will not rest
until every business every corporation
every hard-working successful american
is brought to their knees at the altar
of big government they want mother
government to provide all wound to the
tomb and cradle to the grave housing
food green energy child care medical
care family leave guaranteed basic
income free college free health care
even for illegal immigrants that's what
the 3.5 trillion dollar build back
better what they call human
infrastructure is all about it is
socialism socialism has been tried under
many names many forms and everything is
based on false promises that will never
be fulfilled then we all end up being
poorer and no wrong way then they end up
being poorer and as a result then you
look at how much freedom you give up in
the name of false security now it's the
first down payment and there'll be more
if you allow this to happen of aoc's
green new deal socialism the bill
expands medicare obamacare it includes
money for government funding housing
government-funded medicine
government-funded healthy food gee i
really need their healthy food advice uh
after all they look so healthy joe looks
so healthy to me and of course
government-funded green energy programs
that will be solyndra on steroids and
that's not all the bill also gives
billions in entitlements to illegal
immigrants oh why when other countries
charge for citizenship
why are we offering illegal immigrants
that didn't respect our laws or
sovereignty why are we offering them
uh making them pay
15 million to older americans who are
underserved due to their sexual
orientation gender identity
that's included 50 million to reduce
human wildlife conflicts in national
parks and billions for a brand new
civilian climate corps to stop global
warming in reality this is a radical
transfer of wealth and power from
private citizens to the federal
government even the guy that's running
for new york city mayor guy named eric
adams i prefer curtis sliwa even he says
you know uh in a city of nearly nine
million people sixty five thousand pay
fifty one percent of the income taxes
that's redistribution betsy mccoy
pointed out in her article in the new
york post billions are going to unnamed
community organizations for vague
purposes like promoting community
engagement providing support and advice
translation your taxpayer dollars will
fund the payrolls of left-wing advocacy
groups during elections this bill is so
extreme that two liberal senators they
are now blocking it they're not
conservatives joe manchin and kristen
cinema from arizona joe from west
virginia vote with their fellow
democrats almost 100 percent of the time
they're not a member of the vast
right-wing conspiracy although listening
to liberals you would think that they're
evil incarnate just like every
conservative but even this bill in its
current state is too much for them in
july joe manchin he vowed i'm not going
above 1.5 trillion still a very huge
unsustainable number
frankly unacceptable that is a burden
we're putting on our children and
grandchildren but because the rest of
the democratic party is now completely
insane mansion and cinema almost seem
moderate by comparison there's no room
for moderates in this radical comrade
socialist democratic party there's no
there's none left just soviet-style
socialism and others who try to appease
them nancy pelosi i've been telling you
she's not the speaker she's speaker of
the house in name only she answers to
aoc in the squad and now pelosi is in a
full panic if she's unable to pass the
3.5 trillion dollar bill back better
socialist comrade spending bill there
will be a full-fledged revolt in the
democratic party just in time for the
midterm elections hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else